There is a pattern to the introduction of
technologies.
When Gutenberg invented the press, some
of the earliest authors were frightened of
having their words and thoughts set down and
permanently distributed widely.
Jonathan Swift said that a book of verses
kept in a drawer shown only to friends was
like a fine lass, but once printed as a book
it was like a common whore anyone could buy
for two crown.
Fast forward to the prior kind of moral panic
we’ve had about privacy came because of
a technology.
In the year 1890, the first major law review
article written by Louis Brandeis and Samuel
Warren that tried to look for a legal basis
to a right to privacy in the United States
was inspired by the invention of a technology,
the Kodak camera, and that caused some measure
of moral panic and fear.
The New York Times at the time had stories
about fiendish Kodakers lying in wait.
A young Vanderbilt horsewhipped a Kodaker.
President Teddy Roosevelt outlawed Kodaking
in Washington parks.
Now what happened?
Well, we got used to cameras.
In fact, we’re happy to pose in front
of them as I am right now.
And what really went on there was that a new
technology caused a change that our norms
weren’t ready for, and until such time as
we had new norms, we had new agreements about
how we operated as a society around this,
we were unsettled.
We were afraid what could go wrong.
Well, that's what's happening with the internet
with a much bigger technology that it is.
It’s causing new opportunities.
It’s causing change.
It also causes fear and disruption and sometimes
even a moral panic, which is what I think
we’re going through now.
Privacy matters.
Privacy is important.
It needs protectors.
I have a private life.
All that is true, but we also have this
magnificent tool to publicness, the Internet,
in all of our hands.
We can find, form and act as publics now
in ways that we couldn’t before.
That’s a magnificent ability.
And my fear is that if governments come in
to regulate the 'Net we’ll lose some of
that power.
And some of them want us to lose that power
because they fear that power.
So I think we have to beware of demonizing
technology--things like tracking cookies being
bad for us or worried about technology first
off--because we’re walking into the hands
of those who would limit the technology rather
than what we should do, what society has long
done, is you regulate the behaviors.
So you can use a telephone to do good things
and summon an ambulance; you can use it to
do bad things and defraud people.
The technology isn’t bad.
It’s the behavior we regulate.
Yet nowadays we’re seeing efforts by governments
to come in and regulate on the whole the Internet.
So even Canada and Australia want to filter
all the content on the 'Net to get to pedophilia.
Well, they create an ability and an architecture
that also Iran and China will use.
We have to beware of that.